What advice would you give to someone
looking to quit porn?
Well,
I gave some advice a little earlier
about quitting alcohol.
You know,
and I would say it isn't that you're
trying to quit porn.
It's not the right way to think about
it.
The right way to think about it is that
you're trying to figure out how to have
a better life.
And so you have to figure out,
well,
I would say do the future authoring
program and keep your porn addiction in
mind.
And think so in the first part of the
future authoring program,
it asks you a bunch of questions about
what your life could be like in three to
five years if you took care of yourself
like you were someone that you cared
for.
Um,
and
then it asks you questions about your
friends and your family and your career
and your time outside of work and your
health and you know,
the important dimensions of life and it,
it asks you to spend,
um,
20 minutes writing about how good your
life could be in three to five years if
you got your act together and did what
was good for you.
And then it asked you to write about the
hell you could be at if you didn't.
And so I would say you really need to do
that because porn isn't the issue.
The issue is that you're not living your
life the way you want to.
So you need a vision of life that's more
compelling than the porn.
And you need a counter vision to that
frightens you.
You know,
because otherwise porn is obviously
extraordinarily gratifying in the short
term.
But,
but you seem to be suffering from the
medium to longterm consequences of its
use.
And so you need a story that you can
tell yourself that's really deeply
thought through about why this is not
appropriate for you.
What's,
what.
It's how it's hurting you.
And how it's minimizing you would be
perhaps making you embarrassed and
ashamed and more socially isolated and
all of that.
So I would say think about it as
cleaning up your psyche and your
behavior rather than merely started
stopping,
wow,
stopping poor,
and you also might want to write down
and you could do this in the negative
vision part of the future of the
program.
You got to write down everything bad
that you think porn is doing to you
because obviously you have some
suspicions that this is not good for
you,
right?
That it's that it's actually harming you
in some important way,
and so you need to be fully cognizant of
what those ways are and then take them
seriously and decide if that's the
pathway through life on which you wish
to travel.
And so I up then I would also say good
luck to you.
You know it's,
it's a very good idea to identify one of
your weaknesses and work on it.
Done.
You can.
You can strengthen yourself
substantially by doing that.